remind everybody that we are live
streaming welcome to those who are on
the live stream
uh we have an apology from councillor
abbott
and one for lateness from councillor
clark
uh and i'll also um acknowledge lindsay
mckenzie who's joined us on
zoom would somebody like to move the
apologies please
councillor sopa councillor arnold thank
you
i'll put that all in favor against
kerry just one change to today's
agenda councillors and that is um
the report on the proposed name change
in relation to subdivision
at 46 sunrise drive that
item has been deferred until our april
meeting just while we
work through a bit of resolution with
residents and the developer so that's a
a good outcome there no items of public
forum that i'm aware of and
as always if there are any changes to
the interests register you can contact
malavika at any stage
it's welcome to the meeting to our
representatives from the 2021 youth
council who had their
second meeting of the term last week
ollie and gemma do you want to
bring our representatives up to the
table and introduce them to us
please have a seat it's not like
assembly
or it could be ah afternoon
uh councillors uh my name is ryan frost
and i am the deputy chair for the overs
uh for the youth council
good afternoon i'm alexander i'm the
deputy chair of the unders
and good afternoon my name is jack smith
and i'm the co-chair of the enders
in the first half of the year we are
looking forward to
being part of the hydro slide opening
and the long term
plan consultation process we will be
working with the comms team
again to again on how to
better engage the young people in civics
we have been learning the council wyatt
and hope to sing this
when the unders and overs gather for the
combined meeting each month
we've been invited to take part in the
poppy flight a fundraiser for the rsa
and starship
where a knitted poppy and star
take an air voyage around the country
14 youth council members have formed a
welcoming committee for the artwork when
it landed in vegas
airport on the 8th of april we would
like to invite councillors to join
us official invites will be sent once
times have been confirmed
we have taken part in two local
government uh learnings so far this year
learning about what citizenship means
and we've also did an activity
where we match up the responsibilities
of the council with
correct activities across the city
council ludlow was a big help in this
activity and gave us some valuable
insights so thank you
our meeting last week we also appointed
our representatives
the council subcommittees these included
two library ambassadors
james and connell one role on the active
communities committee to be shared with
two people
by zach and myself and two
representatives
on the creative committee funding
katyana and nasia
last week we also selected our internal
committees
uh for the year uh so we social media
committee we created
which that manages social media for the
youth council
u.n sustainable development goals lead
the leadership committee
youth week and sustainable invercargill
which is a new one this year which is
a committee with environmental focus
around the indica
area we are looking forward to working
with you this year
and if you have anything you'd like to
receive a youth opinion on
you can email youth.council at icc.gov
dot indeed
or tell one of your fellow uh youth
council liaisons councillor ludlow or
councillor crackit
does anyone have any questions
thanks gentlemen well reported it's uh
as i said it's
only your second meeting of the year but
already shaping up with some uh really
cool projects and a really
enthusiastic bunch that councillor
crackit and i are looking forward to
working with questions from councillors
councillor keith yes uh thank you chair
can i show my
ignorance and what are unders and overs
when i was young and so
unders and i was completely different to
what they're going to tell me but uh
yes that's quite it's an age-based thing
around
uh age age or years uh
years but it also can vary on experience
and how many
years you've been in uh youth council
for
yep councillor cricket um i might be
able to shed some light on that
uh initially when we had um when i first
came onto council we had a combined
a youth council of um
the entire group and we found that
sometimes the
unders they've been called now would had
a bit of a barrier to participation they
sort of felt a bit dominated by the
overs because there's quite a bit of a
gap there and um and levels across as
you as you mature
in that age range so we developed the
unders and overs so that everybody gets
equal rights of participation
across both and can feel comfortable in
doing so
thank you for that good question thank
you
any other questions if not we look for
sorry your worship
yes i was wondering if any of you had to
have
have had contact with
members of your organization in going to
japan
uh no i don't believe we have
thank you thank you there are no further
questions
uh i'll move that the report's received
i'll put the motion then all in favor
against
guys thanks very much for getting out of
school early and coming down to present
your report we appreciate it
very good thank you
we've got the minutes of the um meeting
of performance policy and partnerships
from february 9th
if somebody would like to move that
they're a true and correct record
second that mr chair councillor lewis
councillor any questions or comments
if not i put the motion all in favor
against carried
minutes from the extraordinary ppp
meeting on february 16th
it's the remover councillor amundsen
seconded
councillor partner questions or comments
if not then i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried
uh that brings us to the long-term plan
activity plans rhiannon
[Music]
thank you chair i'll take the report as
read
noting that these are supplementary
materials for the
consultation for the long-term plan and
just to note that there are some
changes we're expecting as a result of
the audit process around the assumptions
which will be incorporated prior to
those documents being
available to the public and an
indication from when audit will have
those for us
the audit reports expected on the 23rd
of march and then all those changes will
be made ahead of the consultation
document being adopted on the 29th and
consultation commencing on the 30th
thanks riana questions or comments
counsellors
counselor partner thank you chair it's
um with regards to it's on page 45
it's to do with recession um
recessionary period now
it takes assumptions that uh council
needs to be aware of this for its
budgets
now i guess there's two rules of thought
for a recession um if there's less
development then council would get less
fees from building and etc things like
that but
it's also a common known fact that
during these times central government
and local government
it's an ideal time to to invest in these
major projects
because you would expect the uh the
ability to achieve better pricing
with the lack of work um is is more
favorable
so i'm just wondering that swings in
roundabout and we're looking at
moving into some substantial projects
and what i would call at the moment
quite a peak
building time so i'm just wondering
how what methodology is used to actually
come up with a
with a fine number a crystal ball
yeah um best guess based on on
on global trends and advice from the
financial advisors that
we receive currently but rhiannon is
there anything you'd like to add
to answer only to note that the
assumptions as they appear in this
document where the assumptions
adopted by the performance policy and
partnerships committee
in december and they haven't changed
from that point they will however be
adapted slightly following the audit
process so the final version that
appears in the activity plans
will be aligned and all the material
will be updated
at that point i don't know if the gm
of finance may wish to say anything else
at this point
are you shaking his head i understand
the question
i i guess in in the wake of
um the government's pandemic responses
they've injected a lot of
uh funds into capital works across the
country
uh and if there were to be another
event that triggered a recession i'm not
sure of the capacity for them to be able
to do that again
or the capacity of the workplace to be
able to
meet the demand for any any work that
people were tendering for
um i mean we know that that already
exists as
is um something we need to be wary of at
the present with
the number of projects that are out in
the market but all you can do
is is take an informed guess
and each time it'll be different it's
more how we react
at the time so when it comes to the
annual report that the other end
if there are variances against what
you've signaled in your long-term plan
it's been about being able to explain
why those variances are there
yeah i just i really made the comment
because once you start going into that
recessionary
um debate there's there's two parts
and and it could be either way if you
take a 15
million project say like the museum if
that goes ahead
that that could a 10 swing and that
could be significant
yep yeah any other questions or comments
okay so there's there's two
recommendations sitting there would
somebody like to move them
councillor craic seconded councillor
soper
there are no further questions or
comments i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried
uh the item on
tab nine has been deferred to the april
13th meeting so that brings us to
the pros name change in relation to 360
bainfield road there's a recommendation
or two recommendations
the suggested name meets council's
naming convention
christine have you any comments that
you'd like to add to the report
good afternoon and councillors
um i'll present this report to new road
name
in umbrella estate and stage
two of the development i take it the
report has been read
um have you got any questions
councillors pretty standard
kirsty this is your first meeting
welcome along thank you
uh your role as well i'm the manager of
processing
thank you welcome councillor kit
uh yes just a question uh regarding name
changes
in the past i know the emergency
services get very con
used to get very confused with a number
of streets so we had uh
one lemon street and then a gap in the
middle
we had from bainfield road to
uh right down past through south city
was all alice road
uh they renamed it north and south and
then they renamed it to queen's drive
but with these this name change here
uh these proposed
changes are the emergency services
notified prior to the approval of these
changes christine no they're not
and we said this is a proposed
subdivision it's a new road
it's not a name change in this case
and so once it's got a name
and the plan subdivision is approved by
council
and the plan is deposited and titles are
issued
that is when we advise new zealand post
electoral roles
pear net there's quite a few different
companies and
firms that we notify of the change
and emergency services are amongst them
councillor sopa then councillor lewis oh
sorry i was just going to say i was
happy to move the recommendation
thanks councillor lewis basic question
actually christine have any of the
sections been pre-sold with the
the idea of the purchases
had another name that they might have
been looking at or is it just a brand
new subdivision
it's a brand new subdivision the
subdivider or the developer
may have documented sections tied up
as under deposit but um we would not it
would just be
that sections yeah numbered rather than
named
yes thanks very much
councillors i've got a mover for the
motions so you're a secondary counselor
cracker
so no further questions then i'll put
the motion all in favor
against carried you can run thank you
thank you
uh the reports on local electoral maori
awards and constituencies
michael and jody
good afternoon your worshipping
councillors um
this is a report as i'm sure you're all
aware on the recently adopted and
now effective local electoral amendment
act
has been brought through by the minister
nana
mahuta primarily the focus of this act
was to
disestablish the provision in the local
electoral act for the ability for the
community to have a poll
and overturn a council's decision to
establish
a maori ward so that is now all done in
any polls that were underway have been
devoided essentially
the key issue for us today is in the
schedule to the act
it sets out a transition provision
enabling councils to once again consider
whether they wish to establish a maori
ward for the 2022
trinal elections and so because we are
undertaking our
representation with you currently uh it
seemed an opportune time to have that
conversation with our
community and and of course most
importantly
our partners in this issue are manufa
so we will be talking to the waihopai
and aurora
runaka about this but also mindful our
obligations for
all maori to be consulted and obviously
the wider community
so that is our proposal on this
and then a report would come back to
this committee on the 11th of may
asking the final question do you wish to
establish
a maori ward and at that time we will
have exact numbers
on the people who are would be on the
maori
ward role um so that you've got a bit
more information than we're able to give
you
today we are quite happy to take
any questions so a question of
clarification from me then this is a
process that heparin happens
separate to but alongside the
representation review
yes so essentially each so the local
electoral act is sucked up so that
two years before the next election uh
euro can consider the issue of a maori
ward so that would have been november
last year
when we had workshop and discuss
those those water issues at the same
time you discussed
first-past-the-post and single
transferable vote options
so it's ordinarily separate but
obviously very linked
this time because of the transition
provision we we are in the fortunate
position to be able to do it at the same
time
thank you
questions or comments counselors
your worship and then counselor sopa i
was uh
wondering if you knew what the causes
were but this
policy change
in new plymouth and that or in that area
yes uh your worship i am aware of those
issues that have plagued some of our
uh fellow councils new plymouth being a
uh key focus of that
um the minister's view from what i've
read in the reporting on the bill as it
went through
was that this provision was overtly
racist
and it was overtly racist because
council can and its representation
review
choose to do wards and there's no
ability for the community to do a poll
to overturn that
so it was considered essentially racist
that if council decided to have a
maori ward that that would make it and
then the
community could get together and only
five percent of people could then choose
to have a poll and if only five percent
of the population voted
the maori award would be you know in
theory could be overturned if it was a
majority
so she was very much against this and
against having that ability to make
something that was seen as a positive
for the community
to be taken away from council law's
hands
so that was the policy mindset behind
the
act coming through thank you
councillors thank you mr chair it's not
a question but you did ask for comments
so
my comment would be that the time has
come
and in the interest of equity this is a
very good move
on our part and i'm looking forward to
the report
in may thank you both of you
thank you we've got two recommendations
i'm happy to move those banks councillor
super and councillor amundsen seconding
i'll put it to the vote all in favor aye
aye against
carried thank you very much
that brings us to the welcome return of
the activity report which is something
we've
kind of missed from our meetings over
the the past while whilst we've gone
through
and reject how we do the financial
reporting a lot of the smaller stuff
that we were
looking at tended to
distract a little from
measurements against the the long-term
plan but it also
meant that we lost track of a lot of the
great stories that are going on
uh at a staff level in council and and
trends with
our assorted services so um thank you
very much to
our managers who have put forward this
report
are there any questions i'll take it as
read are there any questions that
counselors have
for the staff while we're here
quite a question with regards to to
libraries
uh if someone wants to have a dig at
that i was just looking at the overall
reduction
to the year end last year and just
wondered if that was as a result of
having
you know um a period of closure during
lockdown uh
that was on 72
72 councillor
mine wasn't really a question it was
just a comment that it's great to see
that all of the
positive things that the council has
been doing to improve services
especially in the building and planning
etc area
are paying off and yeah great to see
the turnaround in building particularly
in the past 12 18 months
is is quite notable there was a great
deal of public criticism about delays so
to see that kpis are now being met and
applications processed within time
frames is really pleasing
so there's a recommendation that the
report is received there's also a note
in there that uh councillors are aware
of the ombudsman
ombudsman's request um that counsellors
be encouraged to use the icc email
addresses
um that makes it easier for council
staff and
and contacting us and knows that makes
it easier for
any ombudsman process around council
issues
that you don't have to worry about
people potentially having access to your
private email account unless you slip
up and send one through that as well in
which case the door's wide open
um so noting that i'm happy to move
the reports received and and that note
for councillors second that
thank you any questions or comments
call i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried we've also got the great south
six monthly report
uh there's no one here from great south
to speak to it sure that wasn't it
thank you i'll skip straight past that
then
um right that brings us to the public
excluded
session of the meeting so if somebody
would like to move that would go into
public
excluded for the reasons as outlined in
the agenda
council lewis seconded councillor
crackit
i'll put that all in favor aye against
carried uh thanks to the members of the
public and the press
who have joined us and thanks to those
who've joined us uh
on the live stream just to note that the
live stream will now be finished
while we go into public excluded
you